>> THIS MEMO IS REALLY A SPIN ON
NOT JUST A SET OF PARTICULAR
>> THIS MEMO IS IMPORTANT TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THE
FEDERAL BUREAU OF INVESTIGATION.
>> IT IS FULL OF FALSEHOODS.
IT'S SHODDY AND POORLY WRITTEN.
>> THIS IS VITAL, ESSENTIAL FOR
THE PUBLIC TO SEE.
IMPORTANT FOR THE BODY OF
EVIDENCE TO GET OUT THERE.
>> IT'S GOING TO GET REVIEW FROM
RELEVANT STAKEHOLDERS,
INTELLIGENCE FOLKS AND FOLKS IN
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THEY WILL BE ADVISING THE
PRESIDENT AND HE WILL MAKE A
DECISION.
>> Bret: WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT
IT.
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE TALKED
ABOUT IT.
A LOT OF TALK TODAY ABOUT EDITS
BEFORE THE WHITE HOUSE SAW IT
AND
AND A BACK-AND-FORTH ON IT.
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
PUTTING OUT A STATEMENT.
IT'S INCREASINGLY STRANGE
ATTEMPT TO THWART PUBLICATION OF
THE METAL.
THE MINORITY IS COMPLAINING
ABOUT EDITS.
INCLUDING GRAMMATICAL FIXES AND
EDITS REQUESTED BY THE FBI AND
THE MINORITY.
THE MOVE TO RELEASE THE MEMO WAS
PROCEDURALLY SOUND AND IN
ACCORDANCE WITH RULES.
TO SUGGEST OTHERWISE IS A
BIZARRE DISTRACTION FROM THE
ABUSE IS DETAILED IN MEMO.
WE THINK THAT WILL HAPPEN
TOMORROW MORNING.
STEPHEN HAYES, EDITOR IN CHIEF
FOR "THE WEEKLY STANDARD" ."
MARA LIASSON, NATIONAL POLITICAL
MOLLIE HEMINGWAY, SENIOR EDITOR
AT "THE FEDERALIST".
STEVE, WHERE ARE WE ON THIS AND
WHERE IT STANDS?
SCENES THE STORY HAS NOW, SOME
OF IT GONE TO IS THE MEMO GOING
TO BE EVERYTHING WE THINK IT'S
GOING TO BE?
>> I DON'T KNOW IF IT POSSIBLY
CAN BE.
SO MUCH HAS BEEN MADE OF IT.
I THINK THERE WILL BE
SIGNIFICANT NEW INFORMATION IN
IT.
WHAT WE LEARN ABOUT THE BEHAVIOR
OF CERTAIN LAW ENFORCEMENT
SENIOR FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS WILL BE TRAVELING TO
PEOPLE.
IS IT ENOUGH TO CHANGE THE
DEBATE IN WASHINGTON ABOUT TRUMP
AND RUSSIA AND THE FBI AND ALL
THAT?
I THINK WE WILL LEARN AT NOON  L
I THINK WE WILL LEARN AT NOON  A
I THINK WE WILL LEARN AT NOON  N
WHAT THE CLAIMS AND
>> THEY WOULD LOVE NOTHING MORE
THAN TO PLAY POLITICS.
DEVIN NUNES HELPED SHEPHERD A
REAUTHORIZATION OF 702.
HE IS FOCUSING ON KEEPING THE
COUNTRY SAFE, FOCUSED ON
NATIONAL SECURITY.
WHAT THEY ARE TRYING TO DO IS
SIDETRACK US.
>> THAT WAS INTERESTING TODAY
BECAUSE HE WENT ON TO SAY LET ME
TELL YOU WHAT THIS MEMO IS AND
ISN'T.
THE MEMO IS CONGRESS DOING
OVERSIGHT OF THE FBI.
IT'S NOT AN ATTACK ON THE FBI,
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE, NOT AN
ATTACK ON ROBERT MUELLER.
THE FACT THAT HE HAD TO SAY THAT
SHOWS YOU THE UNPRECEDENTED
MOMENT.
YOU HAVE THE PRESIDENT AT WAR
BASICALLY FEUDING WITH HIS
HANDPICKED FBI DIRECTOR,
HANDPICKED DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL WHO DIDN'T WANT
THIS MEMO TO COME OUT.
THAT IS SOMETHING WE HAVEN'T
EVER SEEN.
>> IS NOT SURPRISING THE FBI
WOULD BE FREAKING OUT.
THEY HAVE EXPRESSED CONCERN.
NOBODY LIKES TO HAVE THEIR DIRTY
LAUNDRY AIRED.
THIS REPORTEDLY WILL AIR SOME OF
IT.
IT'S A LITTLE MORE DISCONCERTING
HOW MANY OTHER PEOPLE HAVE
JOINED WITH THEM TO KEEP
HE FOUGHT THE SUBPOENAS THAT LED
TO THE INFORMATION.
THERE IS A GENERAL OBSTRUCTION
THERE WE'VE SEEN FROM DEMOCRATS
ON THE COMMITTEE, ALSO THE FBI
THEMSELVES.
THEY SPENT LAST YEAR OBSTRUCTING
REQUESTS FOR INFORMATION.
I THINK IT IS WISE TO TEMPER
EXPECTATIONS.
I THINK IT'S THE BEGINNING OF A
LONG PROCESS OF FIGURING OUT
EXACTLY WHAT'S GOING ON.
LEARNING MORE AND BRINGING IT TO
COMEY STREET.
-- COMEY'S TWEET.
>> ALSO NOT A LOT OF SCHOOLS OR
STREETS NAMED FOR JAMES COMEY
AND ALL LIKELIHOOD.
IT'S ODD HE WOULD MAKE THIS
REFERENCE TO JOE McCARTHY.
PUBLICLY INTIMATING THERE WAS AN
SEE FORMER FBI DIRECTOR, FORMER
CIA DIRECTOR ON TWITTER TOSSING
BALLS TO THE PUBLIC DISCOURSE
LIKE THIS.
>> THEY ARE WELL WITHIN THEIR
RIGHTS TO DO IT.
>> Bret: I AM NOT SAYING IT'S
AGAINST THE LAW.
>> I THINK IT'S INFORMATIVE.
I THINK OUR COLLEAGUES IN THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA HAVE SHOWN AN
IN CAPABILITY OF IMAGINING THE
PEOPLE LIKE JAMES COMEY WOULD BE
YEARS FROM BENGHAZI TO
GUANTANAMO TO THE IRAN DEAL,
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WILL COME
OUT OF THE RELEASE OF THE MEMO
IS WE WILL SEE MORE POLITICS.
DOES IT INVALIDATE THE ENTIRE
INVESTIGATION INTO TRUMP AND
IF THE FBI PLAYED GAMES WITH
FISA APPLICATIONS, DOES THAT
SOMEHOW EXCULPATE
DONALD TRUMP JR. FROM HIS
MEETING AT TRUMP TOWER FOR
MISLEADING PEOPLE ABOUT IT?
THERE IS STILL AN INVESTIGATION
TO BE HAD EVEN IF IT'S THE
CASE --
>> Bret: "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
HAS AN ARTICLE SAYING A P.R.
PERSON IS PLANNING TO TELL
MR. MUELLER ABOUT A CONFERENCE
CALL BETWEEN HOPE HICKS,
PLANNING TO SAY MISS HICKS
HOPE HICKS' ATTORNEY HAS ISSUED
A STATEMENT.
MEETING ABOUT THE RELEASE, THE
PRESS RELEASE.
>> THOSE ARE FOUR WORDS.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT THE CONTEXT
THIS WASN'T THE STATEMENT GIVEN
TO THE FBI.
WHEN I THINK IT'S INTERESTING
ABOUT CULTIVATORS IT WASN'T THAT
LONG AGO THE DEMOCRATS WERE
SAYING THE FBI WAS POLITICALLY
FBI AGENTS WHO LEAKED TO
RUDY GIULIANI, PUT PRESSURE ON
JAMES COMEY TO RELEASE
LEFT AND RIGHT IN THE FBI.
>> Bret: "WALL STREET JOURNAL"
IS ABOUT HOW McCABE WAS
WEEKS.
MAYBE TO GET PAST THE ELECTION.
>> PEOPLE SHOULD THINK LESS
ABOUT WHETHER IT BENEFITS
HILLARY OR TRUMP SO MUCH AS WE
NEEDED FBI THEY CAN BE TRUSTED.
THEY NEED TO FOLLOW PROCEDURES.